hi my name is Nathan schref I'm gonna be
lecturing today about comprehensive
chromosome screening in a human embryo
currently the director of molecular
biology research at Reproductive
Medicine Associates of New Jersey which
is one of the largest infertility
clinics in New Jersey and we
consistently have among the highest
success rates in the United States I'm
also an associate professor at Rutgers
Robert Wood Johnson medical school just
some notes please feel free to submit
any questions during the lecture by
typing them in and I'll do my best to
answer those questions at the end of the
talk so then beat Roe fertilization has
been around for a while dr. Edwards and
Steptoe first performed IVF and
developed the first baby who was braum
many years ago and he recently won the
Nobel Prize fee for that activity dr.
Edwards also pioneered a number of other
fun including pre-implantation genetic
diagnosis where Marie has to be
genetically tested after Kosar in the
petri dish and before transfer back into
the uterus and actually the most common
genetic abnormality that we currently
test for in human embryos is for the
presence of aneuploidy anybody is
essentially the wrong number of
chromosomes where you have too many or
too few and it increases with advancing
maternal age we also know that the
prevalence of infertility significantly
increases with advancing maternal age
which is shown here in this graph where
you can see when orange we continuous
decline when the success of IVF after
transfer back into the same person's
uterus if you were to take
donor eggs from
younger women and transfer back to those
same patients even in had advanced
metrology then get success rates which
are reversed back to what you see in
younger individuals so we know that the
primary one of the primary causes of
infertility is associated with advancing
to college and we also know about it
finally for the significant increases
with advanced maternal age so as a
result of that relative inefficiency and
the success of having a child with
advanced maternal age that we can
actually successfully treat infertility
with in vitro fertilization and we
bypass a lot of the problems but it's
still a relatively inefficient process
despite the fact that it is the most
effective treatment of infertility and
as a result we end up having transferred
back more than one embryo at a time
motor to achieve relatively good success
rate with IVF and so you can see in this
graph that the percentage of embryo
transfers which over time involved more
than one embryo and in 2010 only 19
percent of embryo transfers were
actually a single embryo transfer one of
the problems with this is we have
multiple jurisdictions twins and
triplets proximately half of IVF
deliveries twin deliveries or multiple
gestation deliveries it's because we
transfer more than 100 our back in order
to achieve decent success rates and what
you see in this graph is that with
trying to interpret pregnancies there is
a much higher prevalence or percentage
of births that are preterm and also
really low birth weight infants so
there's a lot of complications
associated with IVF and this is the
primary complication not because your
stage and that's because we transfer
more than them on there
so essentially we'd like to improve the
treatment of infertility by better
selection on videos and we think that
one way to do that is to select others
that have the right number
chromosomes by first screening for the
presence of aneuploidy both in lambda is
private by the selection 400 transcript
unfortunately previous attempts which
primarily involve the use of what's
called fluorescence in situ
hybridization really failed to show the
expected benefit and many many different
organizations came out saying in fact
but there's no evidence that what was
originally trying to cram temptation
genetic streaming a few GS actually
improved outcomes one of the statements
was from the American Society for
Reproductive Medicine I know they
actually did at least suggest that it
wasn't successful the way in which it
was currently performed and then I
really opened up or not the opportunity
divide more technologies which are more
comprehensive than fluorescence in situ
hybridization there are many limitations
of fish one of which is that in fact it
doesn't look at all 24 come zones and
income cells it only was able to work at
about twelve so you ended up
transferring embryos that had
abnormalities for the untested
chromosomes and now for about seven
years
newer technologies have been developed
actually metaphase CGH it's been around
a little bit longer we also have single
nucleotide polymorphisms or snicker a
based methodologies another version of
CGH involving the race rather than
metaphase feds and this is actually well
not common in use now there have also
been gpcr based methodologies and now
there's many labs developing next-gen
sequencing capability again I'll to look
at all 24 chromosomes or Andrea so I'm
just going to briefly talk about some of
the basics behind I feel these methods
before I get into the details with I've
how they've been validated to actually
demonstrate the expected thing well the
majority of these methods are only
possible because of a methodology called
for genome amplification because
when you have Jamie from the Columbia
there's very little material to begin
with so you really have to amplify it in
order to test across the Agena well
there are a couple of different methods
of full genome amplification what I'm
going to show you here is a PCR based
strategy which begins with DNA intact
it's then fragmented I mean an adapter
is ligated which then serves as on their
site which you command me PCR to amplify
all of those fragments well then there's
a variety of methodologies you can use
to characterize that whole genome
amplified DNA as I mentioned snip arrays
array CGH and also now some developing
methods for the next gen sequencing with
one particular type of slip away
what you have is your embryonic DNA
bulging an amplified among there you go
that's hybridized to the right you can
obtain DNA from known normal samples and
process those processes independently
and so those normal samples are also
later the same way but hybridize to
different programs and let me clean
computationally compare the data from
their MBA to the data obtained on other
ways from their enormous samples and
what you obtain is a relative copy
number for all the chromosomes as shown
here with this catalytic for copy of
zero one two three four or five copies
and then in each of the chromosomes and
this is an example a cell that came from
a sample with trisomy 21 that was max
you see an extra copy 1020 and I'm
missing the copy of X because it's not a
Johnny 1 X 20
array CGH is a little bit different so
I've done now you start with ordinal
multiplication and we label your
embryonic dealing with one by the same
process unknown Norman doing that but
over it with a different dye then next
the samples and we can keep for
hybridization to the eraser what happens
is if you have example more do you know
where particular chromosome in where we
are and that particular dial will be
more intense and actually look not green
for example and there's a diamond and in
contrast if they to last to your embryo
has less than an item enormous on a
little work now read only signals can
when you interpret it again terrific
copy number oppressed overcome zones so
you can see the little arrow there is a
tracing with next-gen sequencing
obviously it's it's similar in terms of
obtaining sequence information but it's
massively parallel so you obtain many
reads for a particular region manage
email after you obtain all these
individual sequence reads you don't
alignment to the reference genome I'm on
this example there were fourteen release
which aligned to this part of the genome
essentially what you can do is count the
number of reads which lying to each
chromosome and and so I lose those
relative counts to determine the copy
number of each chromosome and some
groups I've used holding a
multiplication and doing by the
sequencing women everywhere timing the
leads that you get on each firm zone and
then comparing similar process I'm not
on the you know on the amount reads on
sometimes when those samples are
conferred computation on to your Andrea
now this particular methodologies it's
the only development I'm like array CGH
and slipper days which are apparently
clinically
um but there are many groups like I said
developing this methodology so we're
likely to see more like this in the
future another methodology which I I'm
like what I've talked about previously
involves commentated real-time pcs
there's no coding a magnification step
Yarbrough biopsies put into a PCI to
last I mean I'm not like flex PCR
reaction is performed in this really is
a focused PCR instead of whole genome
amplification and it's much faster it's
less expensive and much more flexible
and whole genome amplification in terms
of various applications for
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis once
you've done the multiplex PCR those
samples are loaded onto the 384-well
plate and then real-time PCR is
confirmed so that we worked at
individual positions in the genome
individually we've been independent
reactions the methodology has been
described infertility and sorority you
can actually with this methodology
unlike the others obtain results within
four hours and this really opens like a
lot of possibilities in the clinic
because we often need to get results in
a short turnaround so that exactly we
don't have to crack reserved for embryos
in order to wait for the answer and then
decide the genders to transfer this is
also been applied not only to look at
anybody but also single gene disorders
which are relatively common and then of
the reasons people go through IVF is so
they can have unaffected children
we also can look at translocations and
I'm not a con about DNA mutations
interesting when you lost some amount of
arthritis to look at not the deletions
this is an example of what sort of the
raw data looks like here we're looking
at a sample that we knew is this try
some you're 16 and trust me 21 and what
you see it's basically a heat map
showing a copy number for our phone foot
comes on in the upper left there are
sixteen data points for night rectangle
4 comes in
one and then it goes all the way down to
X and nine we use a relative quantum
method that's previously been described
but with a few modifications to that
math about essentially again we get
these copy numbers and what I've
highlighted here are there areas which
you can see those anchors pop remember
and this is actually funnies on 16 and
21 as we would expect and we also see I
do first about the number for X and 9
because this is from the main sample
when you plot the copy numbers us the
chromosome is this is similar to what it
might look like and you can see again a
vein of 16 and 21 and a glass of x and y
and this happens to be a sample that
really is returning for quality control
I'm not sure that the answer is working
all the time well I mentioned some of
the limitations there fluorescence in
situ hybridization and one of them is
that there was no good validation pilot
every tuned clinical implementation so
we spent a lot of time
really validating this particular type
of screening before a routine clinical
application
I mean referred to it as comprehensive
chromosome screen which Cece is one of
the first things we did was to look at
the pre clinical accuracy and that
embargo from that consistency within
cell lines which had previously relative
to a scalar types as well as consistency
of the numbers we also wanted to
investigate the safety of the procedure
one of the reasons why previous methods
may not have worked well is because it
may have actually been in risk
performing an ending or biopsy so we
looked at both the predictive value
which I'll talk about an impacted biopsy
to address the safety of the procedure
and then of course some randomized
controlled trials to look at the
clinical efficacy again before routine
clinical implementation this is an
example of data with slippery
methodology just illustrating how you
can release Airlines with them
previously well characterized any plate
is to establish the validity
your test our difficulty here is being
able to get an accurate diagnosis from
us in excel on the Left results for
material where you had a large quantity
of DNA from these cell lines
I'm again with the expected karyotypes
which I tucked in there including a
variety of trisomies and then single
cells from those cell same cell lines
were obtained and evaluated and when we
do this in our blinded manner we did
actually demonstrate 98.6%
accuracy on single cell 24 times i'm
karyotyping a similar study was
performed with TBC our event on positive
controls and there we had I accidentally
98% accuracy as I mentioned it's also
important to look at consistency within
tabular because it is possible that the
assays weren't performance in Amman and
actually embryo as they do on cell
islands which are an entirely different
cell type well in this particular study
one of the things we tried to control
for was the non presence of mosaicism
and what actually can not be difficult
to interpret results when you get more
than one diagnosis from the same member
you know it's not clear whether you're a
see itself failed or whether there was
real variation there from the end in
itself
we know that mosaicism exists and it
happens because you can have comes on
areas of her during division after
meiosis I'm doing mitosis so that you
will have some cells for example with an
auntie pudding and maybe some other
cells within the same memory of it
usually so depending on which part of
MDA the biopsy do not get one yourself
none of you Reeboks with another area of
MBR you could get a different so to try
to control for that when testing the
validity of an assay we really focused
here on embryos which had two consistent
diagnoses from two different biopsies
using the slippery and technology well
then rely op see those same ideas and
evaluated them for consistency using a
few PCR
again to try to eliminate the biological
variation from assessing variation of
the acid itself and here we shared a
toxin and 99% consistency between qPCR
and snipper a technology this was also
important because sharing need clearance
at qpc areas never actually allowed us
to benefit from some of the clinical
trials that we would have done in using
snippet eyes to justify the use of qPCR
in future studies we also went back and
evaluated whether or not there a
particular methodology was consistently
from the NBA by looking at a comparison
with fish based methodology here it also
illustrates one of the other limitations
of fish which is really an inconsistent
diagnosis of single cells so here we
took cleavage stage areas which we've
done biopsied on individual cells or
antiperspirant those individual cells
were randomized so that approximately
half were evaluated by fish and half
were evaluated by sniffling and I
mentioned the issue of mosaicism but in
this design the level of mosaicism
should be almost an equivalent in both
fruits and actually when we looked at
the results the fish based methodology
failed to do that consistent diagnosis
and any of the embryos assessed and
actually would have predicted a hundred
percent mosaicism and that was
significantly higher than that level of
consistency yourself Michael a little
only predicted a 31% mosaicism me so
this really Illustrated that fish is an
inconsistent methodology but it actually
leads to a clinical problem because many
programs would perform a biopsy at the
kalidahs stage on a day from the from
fish but then I obtained my own
blastocysts from my MBA which looked
very nice under the microscope and
otherwise would have been considered for
transfer right because the day three
fish came back with an abnormal
diagnosis that I'm where I would
normally be decided but if
but fish actually overdiagnosed a Ducati
you have actually be discarded under it
with potential for the baby so the
question is whether it be whether you
actually described that in there or
biopsy the biopsy and crack preserve the
embryo for additional analysis we
actually did that in about 50 embryos we
obtain multiple biopsies after those
embryos had been diagnosed as only put
on day three by fish and what we found
was that when four different sections at
the same Monday actually all 24
chromosomes or a youth laid the spider
baby fish diagnosis only diagnosis of
Emily and it really indicates that fish
fish really predicts blastocysts
antiquated them likely resulted in
erroneous disposal otherwise this goes
to the negative picked evaluate the test
we really have to address whether or not
your tests inaccurately
make an abnormal diagnosis and whether
it actually predicts a negative program
to do that one one study we performed
with the separators to methodology was
what we call in non-selection study say
the the embryos were selected here you
see a green and blue line they're
selected based on morphology and that's
how we normally select on because in the
clinic but before transfer we biopsied
the NGOs and and saved those biopsies
for future analysis they did undergo a
separate area based on those women we
also used the sniff data to fill offense
so any other is there in frantic DNA
from the conceptus well then comparing
to figure out which of the embryos
actually made the baby we can then go
back and ask whether in that our Smith
array-based stream methodologies
successfully predicted actual clinical
outcome and one of the most important
measures we obtained from this was the
maybe the productive writing but it's
how often we would have predicted
through anybody spoon I made it with
clinical outcome failure to sustain the
temptation and the predictive value of
this particular assay was
extremely high such that we could
actually say we could safely use the
methodology to describe in India
unlike what likely occurred with fish
where there was probably significant
over diagnosis of anything we also so
that data is shown on the right the two
bars on the right the right bar
indicates the negative predictive value
when looking at last names on the black
bar indicates the negative predictive
value of looking at that reflected in
biopsy both in the works were high so we
played successful predict the negative
outcome and we also looked at the
positive beta value which turned out to
be much better when assay was performed
building at the brasses to stage i'm to
us at later in development taking at
reflected in biopsy was more predictive
of positive outcome when the afflicted
youthfully
how much affected in biopsy those
indians sustained implantation more
often than if we played the last command
so there again there a variety of
methodologies one method which was quite
a bit in the clinic today is array CGH
however very little validation number
one evidence actually exists to
demonstrate the validity of array CGH
and diagnose and an accordion and we we
collaborated with a group of motivated
to evaluate
embryos that had been diagnosed as any
for evaluating CGH he looked at about 55
embryos are those embryos were me
biopsied and then blinder before
performing keep pcr-based
competence of chromosomes for me we did
obtain the same result an 87% of those
embryos by 13% they were different
diagnoses we then took those seven on
doors and i've got me biopsied and the
fund blinded slipper it was a frenzy on
screen
we found two embryos in which all three
methods didn't match and this is
actually evidence that there was
particularly under it were in music but
there were five embryos in which two of
the three of methods matched and our
five cases the snicker match that we
pursued our for the array CGH was
interpreted as having in all cases it
was a false positive and for diagnosis
there's an example wherein you see the
release of GH resorb lived in a - m8 and
then in qpcr and snippet and two
different laboratories found on the same
member in a bounded fashion collection
of you later in both cases
again indicating a false positive
uncoated collection by other situation
and then of course zero cases where I
just know I mean ACTH matched indicating
that significantly smaller error rate
from the race ugh from qPCR compared to
a race ugh so I've talked a little bit
about some clinical validation I'm
looking at safety I am evaluating
actually a negative predictive value for
clinical outcomes another important
question in those but when is it best to
find confidence that comes in screening
I briefly mentioned you do those testing
at both the cleavage I'm a classicist
age and it turns out this question
hasn't really been well addressed you
don't know embryo biopsies been
performed for over twenty years to
prevent genetic disease would you think
that it is important to perform biopsies
in order to directly evaluate the
genetics of and therefore not of
different time indications let may
actually be useful to improve IVF
outcomes which I'll talk about in
addicted randomized control trials but
again there's no definitive studies on
whether and the robotic C hinders
implantation or what stages after the
majority of the world really up until
more recently the farms testing at the
previous stage by
an individual blaster as opposed to
effect again again now it's very
important to evaluate these
methodologies and understand what might
be the safest
there are many theoretical advantages to
doing at reflective and I actually owe
them asked me biopsy so what one of the
studies we completed was a randomized
paired randomized control trial okay and
here we identified an offender Contin
two embryos were selected based on
mythology so the best-looking idea is
under the microscope random-ass say that
one had an embryo biopsy defunct and
whoever serviced by controlling is not
fancy he then transferred birth
embarrassed prior to analysis and then
any subtle things which prevent when
doing a finger cunning [ __ ] i'm them if
it was the biopsy the man biopsied
underwear and then over a number of
patients how often was it one another
when we did this bible tonight both
here--let's
by them as the plated stage blasting the
biopsy but we also evaluated the impact
it reflected in fact this summarizes the
results of that study where we're
looking at this is same suspend
implantation right too nervous is
essentially either delivery votes on the
left are the results after clean each
stage box and you can see that there was
a significant reduction in a new
productive potential of embryos that had
a blast in their biopsy performed trying
to read compared to the non biopsy
controls in contrast when you look at a
blastocyst biopsied a retention factor
don't you can see that there was most
significant difference in effective
confidence of a biopsy than mine died
accidentally I've been on this
playground and asking for track as I
mentioned there's a lot of theoretical
advantages I mean when live a blast my
family would stage on do that represents
a larger percentage fourteen percent of
the volume of and or and contrast when
the when the defect I went back to it
that's less than five percent of the
massive
and the question we really don't know
when you take a bath tonight whether or
not that particular those destined to
become part of the undersell mask
actually lending itself or the light
reflective MMH which would give rise to
it was something all right
and also it's actually technically
challenging it doesn't necessarily
impact the actually consider this but
the accuracy of diagnosis sort of single
sailors was not as good as when you have
multiple size so there's some practical
considerations though as well when you
perform at your factor in biopsy in
contrast it's after amber on a genuine
observation against a smaller percentage
of the MBR and it also represents an
extra on beyond of boxes they're not
actually taking any cells from inner
cell mass which is destined to become a
fetus so with all those those
theoretical considerations we actually
perform this randomized trial and
support those theoretical estimates with
actual evidence that lasts in a box that
you are not safe and blasts us by
accident so this is about us not to
exclusively perform Blastoise biopsy
when performing any type of genetic
testing another important set of
experiments are randomized controlled
trials to actually demonstrate we expect
the clinical benefit in the way in which
they will be used to compliment the
first randomized trial that was
performed
whereas with qpcr most comprehensive
comes on screen and we demonstrated a
linkage and foundation right around
where transfer that was in fact
significant almost 20 percent
improvement when using CCS compared to
the patients randomized to the control V
we also seen an increase delivered great
for embryo transfer and increased
delivery rates for treatments occur
which is typically what most people are
interested in so with the new so
comprehensive cleansing screening we do
see them
every night so it does in fact give the
expected clinical benefit when using
most particular methodology a
comprehensive comes in screen I
mentioned that one of the main
complications with IVF is not
registration we started to hypothesize
in make better and other people
suggested a better selection of embryos
would actually improve the success of
sunderland air transfer which we know
will reduce significantly whether of
multiple gestation matthew idea a
retrospective study shown here indicated
that single embryo transfer is without
CCS shown in blue and lower success
rates than those embryos which had
undergone since yes and considered
beautiful and that was true in our age
groups
this led us simplify a second randomized
control trial which is which was a man
inferiorly randomized trial where i
wanted to establish that in fact we
could get equivalent success rates with
a single new play I'm being compared to
the standard of care which is
transferring to hunt screened and what
you see here are the success rates in
blue of the cases where CCS was
performed on a single youth but embryo
destroying speed compared to the control
where two untested embryos were
transferred so we don't see an
equivalent ongoing pregnancy rates which
hadn't been shown in any random
Australia Jeanette single embryo
transfer and then one of the secondary
measures was looking at the risk having
a twin gestation and care would we see
that with similar loop by Blastoise
transfer a hundred percent other
pregnancies as might be expected where
are symptoms that I was almost 50
percent derpity untested last transfer
cases are control in the control group
who actually
twins so there was a significant
reduction in the fragrance it comes with
the use a single you fight on bi
transfer with CCS
so confidence it comes I'm screening has
shown to be accurate using amounts of
controls with known annuities for some
particular methodologies again unlike
fluorescence in situ hybridisation it's
been shown to be consistent within and
ríos looking at blinded analysis and
against other technologies I mentioned
that because of the PCR based nature of
the assay you can actually test for
single gene disorders translocations as
well as insertions and deletions in
parallel and our list can be performed
within a four hour turnaround time which
is the protocol and many cases a
PGD for IBM we've shown that it's safe
to perform through blast biopsy on the
randomized control trial and then it's
effective in improving IVF success rates
we've also shown that it's effective for
elective single embryo transfer
essentially eliminating twins but
maintaining the success rates as
transferred to on tested end and this
methodology realize not really is now
much more widely applied even in our own
clinic in the last five years we've seen
an increase from five percent of our
patients to your almost 70 percent of
our patients who's using this technology
to improve their outcomes and we think
this is also led to an overall
improvement in IVF success rates out of
program future Corrections I mentioned
the incorporation of next-generation
sequencing and you're going to see a lot
more of us
applied to human embryos during IVF and
PGD
we have pelvic recently published a
paper involving the use of NGS next-gen
sequencing for single gene disorders and
I mentioned earlier the post going to be
with a few talks proudly at the American
Society of Human Genetics and
American Society for Reproductive
Medicine means one of the benefits of
having this capability is we can now
start looking for other markers would
leave it up to potential we still see
cases where you numbers productive
employed felt you know baby and so we
think that there are other potential
markers to better select under those as
well as a test for the sink or the
symphony between in the nature and so
what we at least can do is for sure for
annually within these research studies
so I remember taking anybody from the
equation which meant focus on what may
be predicted with then moved on to those
and there are many underlying
technologies such as
time-lapse photography or Martha
automatics proteomics and target omics
there was recently some press around
this time lapse imaging of embryos and
the potential use of those videos to
predict whether or not embryos or cars
only no no unfortunately it's really not
that productive memories that were
predicted to have lower levels of
annakodi
still had thirty fifty six percent
everything condition the embryos were
predicted to be less you played go had
thirty one percent prevalence and repair
done during so we don't necessarily
think that this type of analysis of the
useful for chromosome predictions
equations but with any probe embryos
that going to help to further refine and
there are some populations of patients
which we're still not sure will benefit
from CCS and so we have some ongoing
tries to investigate subsets surviving
the occupations which doing I'm not sure
whether or not there's a benefit for
those and with that I'd like to thank
the organizers like this meeting other
members of my laboratory on
Jersey various funding and collaborators
and those who am I
yeah so are there any questions I'd be
happy to answer yes thank you sure
so anyone interested in and getting the
CME credits can go to this link Iberian
follow the instructions that's it okay
thank you